hello [ __ ] faces hello everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast this podcast was brought
to you by my nuts
a Korean scrotum yeah - my [ __ ]
walnut shaped nuts getting an H Mart you
can get it at 8 smart or any Korean
grocers you could find David Tso's nuts
right there also in your mother's mouth
imported from Seoul did have you been um
do you know anything about Andrew yang
the presidential candidate Andrew yang
yeah I know nothing about this guy all I
know is that he wants to give me $1,000
well I know he was an entrepreneur like
a in the tech world oh yeah that's
that's his background so that's why he
likes to solve things through business
and numbers and and stuff like that I
don't know I like I like how he just
talks about [ __ ] that's based on problem
solution and not so much like identity
politics and [ __ ] like that yeah he's
not he's not really about that game well
just watching him speak is kind of
refreshing for me I mean this is this is
not an Asian bias type of thing but he
sounds very unscripted because when I
was watching the Democratic debates
everybody sounded very scripted right so
there was like the guy who talked about
it was something along the lines of like
murder rates in the city haven't gone
down or something about like cop and
like race relations and stuff he goes to
be honest with you I have failed I have
failed my people I mean the answer was
great right but it sounded so scripted
like we heard they sound very rehearsed
it sound very disingenuous like I just I
can't it's not that I don't really [ __ ]
with that because I feel like a lot of
politicians do talk like that so it's
been around for so long but to hear the
opposite I guess is the same effect that
Trump had right when yeah where a lot of
people like oh he's so off-the-cuff he's
just telling it like how it is but this
one is more he's more pieced-together
yeah and he's a self-made guy right I'm
not sure I didn't do that much research
on the dude but you know what's crazy
so his uh somebody on his campaign
actually reached out to me and I lost I
lost his frickin message oh really yeah
cuz this was right several months ago
right when he was about to get before
Joe Rogan and all
Yeah right so he he basically hit me up
I forgot it feels Instagram or whatever
he DM me and he's like hey I'm a part of
Andrew Yang's campaign would you like to
have him on
just kidding news or something oh well
I'm gonna try to find him again cuz
that'd be awesome if he if we could
bring him down here because you know
like I'm not a liberal he um he he's uh
he's uh he's he's of the left right he's
of he's progressive Democrat right and
um well I'm not Republican either if
anything if I had to choose a political
party I think my ideals are more
libertarian than anything but i-i've
aute independent cuz I I would you know
I'd vote right or left depending on
whatever president I feel is cool yeah
but in Andrews case I think he's he's
he's from the left but he's not playing
the game of the left so the left right
now I think has gone more left or not
moderate anymore there's no real
moderates left everyone except I don't
know maybe Joe Biden Joe Biden is like
of the old guard
but mmm everyone else like Warren toll
see [ __ ] what's-his-name Sanders
Bernie the biggest one yeah like they're
they're more like a new left so bernie
is more like democratic socialist like
so so if you look at the political
spectrum the way it goes is I think it
goes like on the very very left you got
anarchy and then you have communism and
you have socialism then you have Liberal
Democrat and then you have moderate and
in or the middle and then you have a
Republican conservative
Republican conservative libertarian and
then nationalists or something like that
so you if you look at the very very
right and very very left or something
that's that's the whole whole political
spectrum and I think if you boil it down
the more left you go the more you
believe the government should control
everything the more right you go the
more you believe the government should
stay away from running people's lives
yeah yeah
so wait so I think I anarchy might be
the very very very right I don't know
I'm all I'm caught me on this [ __ ] it's
just off the off the cuff so I don't
really
you guys got to look this up but that's
basically the idea of left politics and
right politics one is big government one
is no like no to little government it's
such a weird space cuz I so many people
talk on Twitter you know politics is the
biggest thing on Twitter and Facebook
that's I don't know how it got that way
to I'm just boring man oh that's what
I'm saying man
let my love studying it but I mean it
dude it's like WWE I don't believe none
of that [ __ ] there's a lot of just um
just hardcore adjectives to describe a
whole group of people oh you know it's
like you [ __ ] left this oh you [ __ ]
you know snowflake this you [ __ ]
conservative [ __ ] that I'm like I don't
even know if half the people understand
what they're saying or they don't you
know it cuz like I feel like for me
politics are like the hardest thing is
the hardest thing to get into I don't
know what's fact I don't know what
statistics are right I don't know
anything right because I could find a
statistic that matches this person's
argument but I could find the exact
opposite with the statistic that says
the complete opposite of what they're
saying yeah I think that's the issue
right now is like the whole Eckhart
echo-chamber thing like everyone is like
oh you're stupid cuz you don't have
facts you're not listening to facts
right but then like you said everyone's
getting biased opinion pieces like even
in journalism today like every thought
there's a lot of opinion pieces in not
real journalism like everything is just
what this guy thinks about this [ __ ]
so I mean you Wall Street Journal CNN
all that everybody is like
similar so it's difficult when you have
a narrative fed to you versus just facts
like like a police report right but
that's not entertainment and that's not
good
information because people get bored of
that like people don't want to sit there
and read the actual policies they don't
want to read a police report they just
want to see everything else like no one
[ __ ] read the trayvon martin like
court case and details and everything
yeah i don't want to say no one but it's
very small percentage everybody that was
outraged about it for sure never read
anything but it's the same thing with
everything right like how many
Christians do do you know that don't
read the Bible sure they're so Christian
but they haven't even read the whole
Bible yeah so I think that's the same
[ __ ] with politics like there's so many
people that don't even know how our
government operates they don't even know
what a Senate is they're like what I
thought the president makes all the
decisions I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
serious it's hard man it's it's people
are just so definitive about how they
feel about something that they know
nothing about and it's kind of scary to
me it's like how do you how can you be
so bold with all these like harsh
statements when you when it comes to the
time where if somebody asked you a
straight let's just go back to the Bible
right like if somebody could just break
somebody down verse for verse and
they've they're not even part of that
religion and they go okay well I know
this about the Bible what do you and
they know I don't know I just believe in
it and it's just it's hard it's hard
almost hard to argue or even bring up a
point somebody who's so just enveloped
in something they know nothing about
yeah cuz they just do it off of straight
emotion yeah I mean and that's that
leads to extremism yeah right because
you think you got all the answers
and your team is right and everybody
else is wrong and it's I think it's
getting worse and worse so you know
about Andy no mmm so okay Andy no is
this journalist right he's a
photojournalist and he basic he recently
got [ __ ] up by an Tifa Oh like they
beat him down they [ __ ] gave him a
brain hemorrhage and all that [ __ ] right
what's an tyfa so an tyfa stands for
anti-fascists okay right in this group I
didn't know they exist in the you
I knew that they were always out in
Europe because I would watch these like
I loved watching soccer brawls you ever
see those soccer balls where they just
go [ __ ] yeah fight right and then I'll
see some links of riots and protests
going down and don't have nationalist
socialist groups out there Nazis or
whatever and I think anti-fur was like
the counter so they're like though nah
we want they're like the extreme left
so if Nazism and all all that or
nationalism is the extreme right then on
tyfa is the extreme left and i don't
really know too much of their history
whether like how it formed or anything
but i'm guessing you know they were
probably a bunch of dudes like we got to
do something there's you know there's
Nazis out there and they came together
but here's the problem right Andy knows
Vietnamese and he's gay hooker and
they're they're [ __ ] beating this
dude up oh [ __ ] so it's like in a lot of
members of anti far white so you got a
bunch of white dudes that are that's
fighting for [ __ ] democracy and
diversity and like they're they're
thinking that they're protecting the
world from Nazism and then they're and
these white guys are out there beating
down his [ __ ] gay Vietnamese dude
well in the [ __ ] and here's why they
they they claim that he's a white
supremacist and II know is a white
supremacist this is how crazy it's
getting right so in their mind if you
help the white supremacy you are white
supremacist and you don't have to be
white for that I don't get it either
I don't [ __ ] they call Jewish people
white supremacists dude like it's by
definition you Jewish people cannot be
white supremacist yeah that's who they
targeted that's what Nazis targeted yeah
in not and and people just don't get it
they just think the word white supremacy
they think Caucasians are superior
that's all they think yeah but they
don't understand a definition of white
supremacy is actually Nazism and they
have their own philosophy and Nazism is
highly built off of
Hitler's Mein Kampf his he had he wrote
a book about it and the whole concept if
I could if I could summarize it they
they believe that there's a Jewish
conspiracy out there and Jewish people
control a lot of media and banks and
stuff like that right and then they feel
that they are out there using people and
destroying cultures and all that and
that's why Germans they needed to rise
up because after World War one Germany
was a dirt [ __ ] poor country because
they were the aggressors in World War
one so they're being punished and at the
time a lot of Jewish people were with
their hard work they were becoming rich
in Germany so a lot of German citizens
and locals were angry because they're
like we're white we're poor and all
these foreign foreigners are coming in
and running all of our [ __ ] and like you
know there there's a conspiracy and
that's how Nazism came to power and in
so fast forward to today right like
there's that kind of anti-semitism and
all that still still exists and and so
you got these guys that are out there
preaching white supremacy Nazism and
anti-semitism they all believe that
there's a Jewish conspiracy all this
stuff and then so that's that's what a
white supremacist is but now they're
saying like if you're an alright thinker
or if you're conservative or a
Republican you're not see so they'll
have guys like uh ben shapiro you you
know he's a he's a conservative what
like journalists or he doesn't walk
since a [ __ ] voice yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then um they call him a white
supremacist yeah
and they won't let him speak on camp
campus cuz because they're like he has a
white supremacist ideology and all he is
is just conservative yeah and it's like
what da [ __ ] what's this world coming to
man it's crazy where do these people
[ __ ] find each other I don't know man
it's it's nuts there's even a black
conservative lady named Candace Owens
right and
video of her there's these active uh
guys that are surrounding her and like
calling her [ __ ] racist and Nazi and
all that and get this black woman yes in
the in the guys that's calling are white
that's [ __ ] hilarious dude that's
that's it it saves Chapelle skit right
is it it's the crazy [ __ ] I've ever seen
and there's video you could see this
[ __ ] on YouTube she's being harassed by
an tyfa and then um she had to hide in a
restaurant and these guys are like like
you you [ __ ] racist yeah you big it
and like they're calling her a bigot and
in the Nazi and all this stuff and it's
like yo
does anyone see how crazy this [ __ ] is a
group of white guys calling a black
woman a Nazi yeah racist like he's
[ __ ] nuts man so I hate extremism
from either parties right and um I'm
sure like not all of anti fellas like
that it might be like anonymous where
like it's kind of like a bunch of people
and you got you're always gonna have
some [ __ ] idiots right that are gonna
do I don't know if they all think this
but it's it's just crazy cuz like they
don't get reported no one really like
you know the news doesn't report this
[ __ ] so I'm just like what's going on
man why can't people just like talk and
and and it's just it's just weird I
think just from like the basic
understanding of just people people who
just don't know about [ __ ] rather just
get caught up in the emotion than do the
own research for themselves right so
it's easier for them just to go along
with the group men for them to really
sit down and dissect why they feel a
certain way yeah you know and that's
that's the scary part too because
there's a lot of young people actually
you know what [ __ ] that there's anybody
on Twitter
young or old there's a lot of dumbass oh
my god this book is the breeding ground
for some of the dumbest people on earth
people are just I have this thing I mean
it's not even a theory dude I just think
people in general are the most dumbest
you know what it is I just heard this
podcast and I'm it's so right
like people think we're human like we're
like human first right I'm like nah dude
we're all animals first and people need
to learn how to be a [ __ ] human being
mmm I think we're all animals yeah and
I'm like man if you don't know how to if
you don't no self-control
if you don't know how to deal with your
emotions if you don't have
self-awareness if you don't you know if
you don't have any of these things
you're not a human being you're just
reacting you know you're your animal
yeah and even the underlying thing
beyond that with like politics people
don't realize how big money plays into
it you know like money is everything
good time and they don't know time they
don't see it they don't see them being
swayed by a lot of these days I think
it's also just because for us we're you
understand how powerful money is and how
it what it goes into swaying people's
like perception of things yeah and so
for me it's just like it's a fright like
for example here's something very small
right so I know somebody who lives out
in Texas
and it's an Asian dude Asian guy moves
to Texas and he sees all of this just
highly conservative like propaganda
right just if just just saying like the
war [ __ ] about Democrats and just you
know you you see all these like
different like cut up videos where it
doesn't show the whole story and you
know it just constantly going on these
Facebook rants saying like you'll [ __ ]
Democrats [ __ ] these like snowflakes and
everything else and mind you know he's
showing me these things and I go on
Facebook I go on Facebook that often and
I seen this stuff and I see some other
media company talking about the same
thing but it's different evidence right
and there's taking what they're doing
and chopping it up too and so I've known
this guy for a very long time and I hit
him up I was like a bro so what do you
really feel this way like it's cuz the
facts are there I was like cool well let
me show you something real quick
and I and I sent him I showed snapshots
of my on my Mac and all my feet right
and I was like this is my feet and look
at your feet you live in a highly red
state I live in a very blue state this
is what we see it's funny that you you
think that this is what your Facebook is
everybody's Facebook it's not it's
catering to the people that are around
you it was the cameraman exactly and so
he was like he was like oh but you know
those really aren't effects these are
fast well what makes your fax that's
called a cognitive
yeah and I was telling him is like I
don't I don't have my foot in this game
I know I don't know [ __ ] about politics
but I do know that when you go on this
as a [ __ ] 40-something general adult
and you're going on these rants about
[ __ ] but you don't [ __ ] know about
like for example it was that's [ __ ]
fine yeah and I was like I was like for
example let me just say this I rolled up
one of his post writing he was going on
this whole diatribe about like why he
loves Trump you know and yeah you know
mind you forty something in all the
Asian dude you know which is very odd
yeah and and I was like okay this is why
you love Trump that's like cool well let
me just ask you real quick before you go
on you know you wrote this whole
diatribe about you know why you love him
and what he's going to do cool
what are his policies that you like she
doesn't know he doesn't [ __ ] know he
doesn't know and I'm like dog then how
[ __ ] dare you go on like this whole
week tirade about how much you love
Trump how crappy Democrats are like how
Republican you are when you don't even
know the policies that he's gonna bring
into is you know this is before he
became president so it's like this is
such an odd thing for you to do
especially and he's not even a little
kid because a lot of people like to bash
young people for guys he's a [ __ ] 40
year old man yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] were you thinking dude I don't know
man I think what sucks is that people
have to recognize that at the end of the
day the game of America and we have to
we have to realize as Americans it's
like okay we fight on at the at the
election but once we get that president
in let's back this president up of
course we don't back them up blindly but
that's it's our president yeah so for
the next four years let's just we voted
this person in right but then people are
still just against it
so like when Obama was elected like
people were still against it calling him
like Obama's a [ __ ] immigrant Obama's
a terrorist like what the [ __ ] right
like it's like there's so much distrust
and you got a I don't get it like you
got a you got to play the game and then
back them up and go yeah he's our
president and hope that he does good and
then wait till the next election
embattled battled it out again
of course you're gonna have corruption
from time to time and whatever you got
to fight that but I honestly believe
that a lot of this is being played on a
level that US normies just do not
understand hmm there's things that
happen and chess pieces that are being
moved on a higher level that I don't
think I have the information so like
whatever the media is giving us whatever
we see on the surface whatever the
official yeah White House statements are
like I'm sure that there's something
else going on I mean we see this in
Hollywood and YouTube all the [ __ ]
time apology videos whatever like
scandals right drama that purposely was
instigated to drive up a sale like we
see this [ __ ] on a day-to-day basis so
what I tell people is like make sure you
don't emotionally invest into anything
if it's not you and your friends and
family you know so ideas political
groups even religious groups and
whatever like don't put your heart and
soul into absolutely anything that you
do not know a hundred percent so for
example if I if I give my [ __ ]
dedication to like let's say the
Democratic Party right like unless I'm
trying to be a president or like I'm a
politician in that party or I'm deeply
in and in it like it's difficult to
what's the word it's like you can't
trust that organization to commercial
your life we're just Outsiders looking
in yeah we're coming up with these
conclusions with stuff that people are
feeding to us right you're not there
from the ground level so we don't even
[ __ ] know how do you know that
they're not playing you know because
once you give your emotions up and
you're you're reacting to something
right they got you that's when they win
and what I mean by that is like so for
example Kim Kardashian and Trump does
this so [ __ ] genius Lee right they
can stay in your face because they know
how to play with the pettiness of human
beings so like they'll say something
that's
just enough offensive but not illegal
Mike Kim just busted out her kimono line
oh yeah look at the clothing right that
outraged so many [ __ ] people so many
people got angry
imagine if nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah and
she you think she really would have
continued with that nah dude like no one
would've gave a [ __ ]
and then she purposely did something to
outraged the public eye I personally
think like they're kind of genius in the
way that they know how to manipulate
scandal and it's it's it's evil genius
it's not genius in like I'm not saying
good job genius I'm like wow dude like
no matter how much it's almost like a
burning building right and I'm like no
matter how much I'm knocking on people's
doors and saying look dude like the
building's [ __ ] burning people don't
want to believe it
I think it's also because people expect
our government and people in those type
of high positions that that they're
better than us so they won't do these
type of things that they always want to
believe in the best yeah because if I
were to break it down to somebody who
just don't who doesn't believe that and
all especially a young person like if I
guess if I could really relate to them
it's like these youtubers they have
created fake scandals in order for you
to make sure that they do give them
their an undying attention yeah right
so what makes this person in this public
eye anymore better than what who's to
say that that your politicians wouldn't
do the same oh they'll do it to grab
attention a thousand percent yeah and so
I think it goes to that thought of
people just wanting to believe that
people in our government are above those
type of things and I don't think they're
above and I think they do it the best I
think they do it better than us they
really so there's people so it blows my
mind that people actually trusts the
government and verbatim like what they
say is what they say yeah and what they
mean like I'm always looking at context
and reading behind the line I'm reading
between the lines and like who's really
benefiting from this policy or where
does the money go it's always tied to
money man when I when I tell people like
okay when it comes to these civil issues
right like things that don't really
budge or change much but people always
fight
for gun rights abortion gay rights race
issues right so like all these things
it's like an ongoing conversation in
America that's that's just going back
and forth and back and forth these
things might change but the things that
don't really change between the two
political parties is they'll never ever
bite the feed that hand that that that
the hand that feeds the hand that feeds
them right just just do this watch but
that's why I think people like Bernie
and Trump cuz like these guys are [ __ ]
crazy like they'll come out and do
things that were never done before but
for example do you tell them alright um
put pressure on the pharmaceutical
industry never [ __ ] do it they won't
do it
yeah put pressure on the
military-industrial complex they don't
even know what that is most people hmm
there's there's war profiteers right
like we have a whole system in
Eisenhower said this like beware of the
military-industrial complex and a lot of
it's crazy because Trump outright
admitted when the Iran should happen he
was like I don't want there's a lot of
people around me that want to go to war
I don't want to go to war and so he
killed that and and we're not going to
war with Iran but there's war hawks in
our government because CIA in all the
departments if we go to war they get
more contracts they get more money they
get more you know it just they get more
jobs and in it stimulates their business
right so the military is like any other
business how do you stay in business you
have to fight wars you have to build
missiles you have to [ __ ] to build
tanks right so it to me it's like it's
so simple it's like they're like why
camp why am i when i start talking
they're like all your crazy that's
conspiracy and it's like no that's
common sense no like the militant the
military is a company it's a registered
company it's an operating business like
they get paid to [ __ ] serve like a
soldier
they get paid after they go to war for
serving yeah they don't go for free you
know like for other American duty they
just [ __ ] you know like it's a business
you know and it just blows my mind that
people don't understand that there is
money trail to everything that's being
done yeah I feel like if anybody can't
agree with you know people have their
own thoughts about things but I think
everybody can't agree that money moves
everything it I mean at least in America
sure money moves everything everybody's
choices why they choose to support
something why they choose not to support
them because some because if it's not
dollars going to your pockets why why do
you [ __ ] care even for me on like the
ground level I'm there like why do you
live Andrew James Andrew yang so much
he's gonna give me a thousand dollars a
month which is a very good campaign I
feel like
on the basis on a ground level it's like
all people here is a thousand dollars a
month and he talked about automation now
people taking your jobs away he's
essentially doing it might what my
personal opinion what Trump was doing
just a lot smarter yeah you know and in
terms of like yo your jobs are going
away and I actually have a real solution
for you not just yo [ __ ] these people
that are trying to take oil away it's
gonna go away
it's a finite amount that's these are
facts it's a finite amount you know it
will go away eventually there that he's
gonna bring back coal mines and all this
other stuff but Andrea is tackling in a
different way you know I know it's gonna
disappear and your jobs aren't being
automated away well let me show you this
solution right we have all this [ __ ]
money here and we're putting the things
that we don't see we could take just a
chunk of that money and give you a
thousand bucks a month it's gonna cycle
that money back into our economy it's
gonna create more jobs simple solution
there you go bing bang boom and for me I
don't know too much but it sounds great
yeah it sounds great for sure and I
think he's talking to the common person
yes he is cuz I'm the common person and
it's working
Trump won cuz people were just sleeping
on like the the left was completely
sleeping on you know people that were
just losing jobs to manufacturing and
like they just didn't understand like
the common person's plight and even for
me to because I live in California we
live in a very tech heavy area yeah
that type of problem to me seems so
small and I forget how much of this
country is like middle America yeah and
to me they just didn't exist yeah and I
mean like they might care about gay
rights here and there but they're there
I think people first and foremost care
about how they're gonna feed their
family yeah like I'm like I don't give a
[ __ ] about if if if my son is gay or not
it's like I'm trying to feed them ya
know like I don't know what to do I
think that's that's a that's a really
strong case to talk about it's like I
mean if people don't even believe that
money moves things I mean think about
something like this right just five
years ago almost five years ago it's
been like that right weed was
criminalized yeah what do you think the
reason why it's not now well cuz the tax
is like twenty percent you're not they
take a lot of [ __ ] money
yeah and people it's like that's
something as simple as that right
because weed was the crazy drug we
always the stuff that was a gateway drug
for you doing cocaine LSD all that other
[ __ ] right you know but all of a sudden
hey man what are you talking about weeds
great and hey it got illegal is actually
a money move - oh really
yeah man so this guy had a patent for
arm I think it was like polyester or
some mixed fabric [ __ ] right and then um
this dude came out with an invention on
how to like process hemp better so hemp
is actually just marijuana it's the same
thing right but there were a lot of hemp
products in the u.s. like the plant is
awesome and you could weave baskets we
could [ __ ] build a lot of [ __ ] with
it and this guy worked with the
government to make it illegal so that he
could sell his like mix fabric [ __ ] okay
and then so they branded they made they
made a hemp and marijuana illegal
because basically like they're like yeah
they came up with his word cuz uh I
guess like you know they go oh black
people with Mexicans are getting high
off of this crazy drug and they had this
whole campaign to demonize it so it
wasn't always tied to money yeah and
then can you
of all the people that's been going to
jail criminalize all that just for
smoking some weed you know it's crazy
man and so many lives were ruined
because of this law
but there's yet I think there's popping
up a marijuana museum pretty soon it's
like it's like in LA somewhere I want to
go check it out but it's like the
history of marijuana I feel like
sometimes too like criminalizing certain
things that don't really have that much
of a harmful effect in to a certain
extent right makes you want to do it
more yeah you know you know I mean like
even like alcohol like it makes me want
to drink it more based on the fact that
you probably shouldn't and that was
illegal and look at how much the Mafia
profited because it was illegal you know
and it all goes back to money right so
like and they legalized it because they
don't want to miss out on the tax
dollars it's is just crazy like I don't
understand why when I bring this up
people think conspiracy or other things
and it's kind of like this so I'll you
even bring it back to earth where it's
like Hollywood right people think
Hollywood is very racist and I go no
they're just greedy they might be racist
I don't know but I think they're first
and foremost very greedy and so I'm like
yeah cuz they they go where the money
goes right and then lately there's been
more there's more love toward the Asians
right so like they're like oh Milan is
finally they're finally Disney's doing
the right move and finally you know like
right movies because it's gonna make
money dude BAM right you know why cuz
the first Moulin didn't go popular in
China they're like the [ __ ] [ __ ] this
story like this is fake they got a
talking dragon and [ __ ] that's why they
wanted to historically accurate Mulan so
China will buy ya the Avengers [ __ ]
made 600 like mil domestically but 2 for
2.5 billion internationally yeah right
so I think they made like dollar for
dollar the same amount in China or some
[ __ ] like they made a [ __ ] ton of money
in China it was like four billion yuan I
don't know and like you know for this
stuff that's you I guess like
progressive in a positive way like I'm
that wave of like I really do appreciate
it you know but to say that the reason
what for example they take your credit
to Disney you know that stuff like we're
not just Disney let's just use any
company right and they go dude that's so
progressive of them if it was it wasn't
based off of feelings yeah if it wasn't
profitable yeah
would it have [ __ ] done it hell and a
period end of story and um if it's
there's nothing to argue with that it
isn't the business a hundred percent if
everybody was against it and they knew
that they weren't gonna sell anything
with it they wouldn't have made that
move they wouldn't have made such huge
statements about right even in terms of
things that are bought like
body-positive
right if you like if if everybody was
against Nike selling larger clothing
they would not have done a larger
clothing line where they show how bigger
mannequins of stuff is because everybody
is in a good way to it's a positive
thing that is happening in my personal
opinion but to say that that company
made that move based on a moral decision
is a very shallow way of thinking right
because we all know that American is
America is one of the biggest obese
countries in the world so they're gonna
sell a for-sure gym clothes for sure for
obese people it it's you know like what
the [ __ ] you know it's like duh yeah I
mean I guess maybe maybe a lot of people
don't see the world this way so they're
hoping that people are moral and they're
like well there's probably somebody
there that fought for this it maybe
that's true but at the end of the day
decisions are made by companies and
politics and business because of a lot
of it is because of money yeah a lot of
it is I don't want to say all of it you
know no cuz there might be like some
like let's say Nike CEOs wife really
cared about something and then she was
like you know honey I want this and then
he was like well maybe I'll I'll try to
put it in like that happens too
you know or like their kid is really
like fighting for something and then
they're like dad would you would do this
yeah like that those things happen but
like I think in general if you look at
how things are working it's always tied
to like someone getting paid group
getting paid group benefiting or group
winning
yeah in some way shape or form it's
never like oh man they don't want to
hire as Asians dude they'll hire us
Asians in us Asians only if we made a
locked on our money for them yeah if if
if Asians if asian male leads were were
we're getting like billions and billions
of dollars like all the time then we
would wipe out the competition and
there'll be no other male leads but us
man even goes further into talking about
let's not even touch talk about on a
human level talking about certain topics
that are controversial or quote-unquote
what people say is controversial yeah it
doesn't me just give the mindset about
gives him like social currency right for
example when we when we first started
doing what we were doing right we just
wanted to represent who we were right
and then during this time there were it
wasn't like too many people like backing
us up saying like oh yeah there are
Asian people like that or whatever there
was a certain amount right yeah that's
true but now the wave is like Asian
Americans need to stand up and all of a
sudden these [ __ ] come out the
woodwork is like yo man I've been
supporting you know Asian man we need to
get more Asian Americans on the screen
it's like yeah where the [ __ ] were you
you know eight years ago I know and you
weren't there it's easy because you can
do that now because when you write that
on Twitter you get 800 likes a thousand
likes you're getting social currency
from it yeah just on that understanding
you should understand how important it
is or how money works right right if it
works like that on a social level it's
clearly gonna work like that on a
monetary monetary level because back in
the day when it wasn't really cool to
say that you were scared you were just
like no you didn't have the courage yeah
you're looking around your shoulders see
if other people are agreeing with ya so
you you I mean people know that they do
that I see a lot of Asian Americans who
were very quiet before that are now
they're puffing up their chests and they
feel like they can talk now yeah they're
just talking [ __ ] about everybody else
it's like yo men like you weren't there
when it counted the most now it's easy
for you to do that now it's is not
really brave like so this it's like this
it's like in the in the 60s being that
asian guy marching down while police are
[ __ ] like spraying hoses like water at
you and smacking you around and you're
fighting
um to get the asian-american studies
into your University Asians had to do
that [ __ ] right they had to actually
literally fight and lock down campus I
think it was Berkeley or whatever so we
could have a multicultural Studies
Program mm-hmm and it's crazy because
they were having [ __ ] thrown at them for
doing this and I'm like okay that's
ballsy
going on Twitter and having a few
thoughts that to me I don't care what I
don't give a damn how people say think
think about me but I think that's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] well yeah that is a complete
weakness or a hundred percent and what
and you know I'm like I love [ __ ]
Twitter dude like Twitter makes me
laughing but I love talking [ __ ] yeah
there's some funny [ __ ] on there you
know but when I see some of these things
that people post where they go you know
what you shouldn't treat people like
this because of this oh that's how
you're doing it because you're trying to
see what's that what that emotional
tickets and other people have so you can
get the retweet yeah it's not because
that's a moral stance of yours no you
just try it's like that one one Asian
kid that was that that work that went
viral calling that little white girl in
a Chinese dress he [ __ ] he [ __ ]
talked [ __ ] saying your dress is not my
coat like my culture is not your [ __ ]
costumes or whatever right and then
later people dig up all this [ __ ] he was
using the n-word he was like a hard
[ __ ] are yup he was talking mad [ __ ]
it's like man you ain't about that
[ __ ] act of his life dude it's so
[ __ ] dumb you know it's funny too cuz
we did that video where we were talking
about the you know the whole who said
Dean Deano and chemo or whatever you
know the the poncho people that they
they were out in [ __ ] Highland Park
yeah yeah yeah and some people you know
there was like some Mexican folks that
were like oh we don't care people wear
ponchos and I was like oh that's cool
that's that's understandable but how you
feel about that doesn't mean that those
people who live in those heavily Mexican
areas that are Mexican they can also
feel like they're not cool with it too
yeah you know like you can't speak for
that whole culture I guess I mean we
kind of we all do that sometimes yeah
because we're putting ourselves in those
boots I think the the poncho wasn't an
issue like Poncho's are hot I've been
like in the last like two years ago like
Poncho's got really big people we're in
for fashion right
but wasn't the poncho that was offensive
it was the [ __ ] mustache the sombrero
the [ __ ] I don't know what they were
recording yeah they're making that I
think that dude in the video was upset
because the guy was trying to profit off
of making fun of Mexican people oh
that's what it was they're always mad
about the actual poncho dude you know
what I mean like I [ __ ] used to wear
sombreros all the time just because it
kept the Sun out of my can i used to get
it at the flea markets a lot and this is
all mexican folks it's gonna create
people put all their all the times I see
like sombreros wells used to working at
this place called denials out in
Sacramento I feel like people are just
getting more and more socially stupid
yeah they just don't understand concoct
a context context like I throw this word
around a lot but I just want people to
understand the just words and things are
just like objects or something yes yes
and it there's a feeling attached to
that and you got to read what that means
and it takes time but man it's it's just
damn there's so much misunderstandings
going on yeah like for example you know
skating summer and it gets hot there's
something that I wear so my a really
good friend of mine named Amen her mom
got me a [ __ ] does she can when she
went to Africa yeah the summer because
it's nice and cool right but I meant to
be in how like hot girl is yeah I like
the way it feels I like the way it looks
is dope right and I'm not going outside
wearing a [ __ ] it wearing the dashiki
going how are you today
yeah my name is David I know hello my
name is Dave what do you want to do
today like I'm not I'm not going out
there with the African accent I'm
wearing the the [ __ ] dashiki because
it was a gift and I like the way it
looks at his dope you know what I mean
I'm not mocking the culture I'm
appreciating it right and even then some
people have some [ __ ] to say to it right
they'll be like oh we're like don't wear
that [ __ ] it's like it's like broad but
do you have a [ __ ] best shitty
straight from Africa give it to me by an
African woman you shut the [ __ ] up yeah
she tells me it's okay I'm gonna [ __ ]
wear it um you know that's just crazy so
yeah so context does matter right I did
read a lot of stuff too um because we
don't have fans that are only from
America right like we have or Western
countries like we have Malaysia fans
like Singapore fans like fans that grew
up in Asia all their lives but
went to international school and a lot
of them I read that they don't
understand like pay what's the
difference of cultural appreciation and
cultural appropriation and they're like
I don't understand mine why interesting
line huh yeah cuz they're like when when
people come to our countries and then
they they dress up in our traditional
stuff and play around and we're like
dude that's so awesome like feels like
we're sharing our culture and I think it
was like a huge like discussion I it
might be in that videos comment or
something like that but I was reading it
and I'm like man genius brain fans are
really [ __ ] smart because a lot of
people were trying to decipher it like
they're like hey I'm another Malaysian
too and like I think it means like when
someone takes over your culture and then
like they mess it all up and and they're
trying to like own it and I'm like oh
that like it's cool because I said it's
cool you know yeah
and that's that yeah it's kind of really
hard to explain I think just cuz America
is like race relations is something
that's so [ __ ] sensitive here right
yeah I'm pretty sure there's a in other
countries is there's some [ __ ] like that
too right but for some reason in this
country when it comes to ethnicity and
race I mean just just because of like
how this country has been the foundation
that's been based on and a lot of the
[ __ ] that's happened people who aren't
from here or grew up here they don't
understand it right so yeah a hundred
percent I mean even that one girl in
that video that we were talking about
she was like what is she like Eastern
European and she's like hey I'm an
immigrant too like I'm on the same side
but it's it's we all kind of go well it
doesn't kind of count cuz you're white
yeah you know like no that's true but
why not cuz there are poor white
immigrants that come to America - it's
just like history behind it that a lot
of people just don't wish to acknowledge
my mean not not wish to acknowledge
because they just don't know about it
right yeah so somebody like that she is
an immigrant she doesn't understand as
she it is the history part yeah yeah I
think that's that's exactly what it is
and and the the fallacy on her part is
that she wants people to understand that
oh I'm not from here so it's okay for me
it's like know when you go to it's like
us anywhere ever country that you go you
have to adjust to how that country is
yes right you can't
course what you believe in how it was
for you in Eastern Europe here in the
States it doesn't work and it goes the
other way around hell yeah that's like
me going to Japan and being like why
can't I [ __ ] complain at the
restaurant yeah the way I want it done
my way like I don't want [ __ ] eggs in
my [ __ ] yeah they'll be like get the
[ __ ] out dude like then why did you come
here yeah and it's like [ __ ] yeah it's
different place it's it's it's such a
weird place to be and and I feel like
with race relations now specifically in
this country people are just being a lot
more mindful of it so the it's it's like
it's so shaky it's like everybody's
[ __ ] walking on eggshells right now
well I think we're more diverse now than
ever before which is a good thing but
this is what's going on I think America
actually have been we all share the same
country but it's been very segregated
mmm for a long time right like there's
white bubbles there's Asian bubbles sure
there might be some cities where there's
some mixing and then some groups might
have some multiculturalism in their
group but for the most part right people
stuck to their own groups mm-hmm and
unless you're very Americanized if
you're immigrant that's even more
apparent like immigrant communities or
whatever they just stick to like the
Vietnamese town or whatever right but
now this is what's happening is that in
the past you only had the media being
the funnel and controlling the
representation of the black people or
what the Asian people think right now we
have the internet and we can be
ourselves comfortably like no one has to
act a certain way in front of white
people to make them comfortable or we
can see what rich white people think so
differently from poor white people we
can see the difference in region and
we're all sharing this one big
conversation together so there's gonna
be fighting there's gonna be people that
are still alive today that experienced
segregation and racism more online so
there's a lot of pain from them there's
white kids that grew up in a complete
bubble that had
no idea that this pain existed mm-hmm so
like Jess she didn't know she thought
that this was all history and she didn't
know that there was actually still
tensions today mmm because I mean she
only grew up with mainly whites and then
Mexicans and in the the Mexicans they're
cool or and then and there's no race
tensions so like maybe because it's a
small town so everyone got along but
like yeah she was kind of like damn dude
I didn't know that all this stuff really
was still tense you know and um I think
yeah so when you get these people
together now we can talk like online
right like like what other time that we
ever have in our history where a poor
asian kid you know from Gardena can have
a conversation with a you know rich old
white guy in New York hmm or whatever
like or like a like a like a straight-up
southern like tobacco farmer watch a
genius brain episode be like yo these
guys are funny and they're like you know
like this is crazy right so then now we
have this like multiculturalism and
diversity and talking and all that and
then people are finding out I think why
people are finding out that they weren't
so popular after all oh yeah they're
hearing all the thoughts of how what
minorities think they're hearing our
thoughts and like the pain and they're
just like whoa oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
sucks mm-hmm so you have some people
that are like I got to do something
about this and in there hella liberal
they're they want to talk for minorities
and it's like old you don't have to talk
for us but yeah just be with us you know
or whatever and it's just different and
then you have the other one that's like
yo man I was never born during this
whole racism [ __ ] and I'm just a new
white guy and why the [ __ ] am I the bad
guy you know like you know and I think
all these crazy things are happening
right now and we'll work it out yeah
yeah it's you know opinion versus facts
to a lot of people lack tact when they
say things Oh things get especially over
text yeah things get things get [ __ ]
Oh Twitter is that like Twitter is the
best example of it you know
so well you guys well that ends this
episode the Jesus brain podcast very
political this one yeah I think you know
what people have been asking about these
type of thing because like like I said
one of the things that I hate the most
is when when I go on any type of
Instagram platform and they ask you you
know you should talk about politics like
they don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] about
politics I'm not saying [ __ ] it's when
they when they talk about it yeah they
talk they attack influencers right big
oh yeah oh why the how [ __ ] Gary King
bats not put his two cents about
politics maybe because the [ __ ]
doesn't know what if he's a something
that you don't like yeah they want to
hear about her political views it's like
well what the [ __ ] what makes our
political views viable listen to
politicians about their political views
nice [ __ ] normal ask people like
especially like entertainers
entertainers or some of the dumbest
[ __ ] on earth exactly like
we're clowns ma'am because this is all
just opinions and thoughts and you know
sometimes people get upset they go well
it's like well you I can't believe
you're saying these facts I never said
they were [ __ ] facts okay this is
just dealer just my thoughts you you run
it you run with it however the [ __ ] you
want yeah I mean yeah the politics gets
[ __ ] touch you man you just gotta be
so careful I don't give a [ __ ] I just
want it I just say [ __ ] yeah it just
it's done based on your own research
right yeah and I love I love politics in
a way that it's like I want the same way
I look at conspiracy drama homie yeah
it's it's just fun it's just
entertaining yeah it's not even like
real and someone when you when you come
to these like conversations I feel like
a lot of people want to be very
argumentative and hate certain things
but if you are gonna do that I say like
come ready then you know can't come
ready come ready to the table with with
facts that you think to be true and then
you can have a civil discussion that's
why that dude was his name a steven
crowder yeah he there's a reason why he
goes to college campuses and he wants
random college kids to come it's easy to
catch him slipping yeah cuz he has his
binder full of facts
he studied and he's ready to go his
statistics but then you come up as an
emotional 18 or college kid that just
hates what he does you're not gonna win
that argument and you have to understand
too from that guy's point of view he has
tactics in order to make you sound dumb
even though you're not dumb
you know that's like his skill set so
yeah you know a lot of the times they
he's not saying anything that wrong or
controversial it's just stuff that hurts
their feelings yeah you know like
there's a lot of stuff that he says that
I disagree with and I'll sometimes a
couple of his videos like I was a couple
like maybe three or four of his video
and there was a one video where he got
destroyed by this kid yeah it was time
they were talking about socialism yeah
and this kid comes up and [ __ ] rips
him dude like in in you know and because
he was losing the bait [ __ ] steven
crowder became like the college kids you
know he started like making fun of the
kid like holding in his face putting him
off and as every time he tried to say
something very poignant in his
conversation he would try to deter the
conversation to say well what does that
word mean well what does that word mean
explain with that because he's trying to
make the kid sound it was so funny
because he put up the video in guys of
thinking that he actually destroyed this
kid but when you looked at and you read
all the comments like dude this [ __ ]
like nineteen year old kid just
destroyed you because he got flustered
he so you know it happens with him too
yeah the reason why I like guys like
that is that they make it about the
conversation yeah
no more extremism like yeah people if
you debate you don't have a green if you
don't have agreements it's fine but talk
it out in person put it on like have
discussions that's what this whole [ __ ]
is about you know there's you know he
know like his topic of like changed my
mind isn't changed my mind he's one he
wants to debate someone yes so come
ready make you show already just come
ready and that's the battlefield man
that's like let's have a rap battle and
then you can't come in and be like but I
just want to play the drums yeah that's
not a [ __ ] rap battle go like [ __ ]
come ready with your [ __ ] lines yeah
man dude well guys that wraps up this
episode of the Jesus brain pot Jesus
Jesus gene that brain genius brain
podcast you could catch us on iTunes
Spotify cash box whatever that it may be
make sure that you leave us a five star
on iTunes leave comments below talk
about your opinions have discussions
with each other don't even you don't
even have to talk about the stuff that
we specifically said and respond to us
talk to other people in the comments and
also we got a patreon now - yep yes we
do Tom slash
genius brain we have exclusive things
that we want
talk about especially it's it's it's
it's special for my genius brain fans
because they're all all the content is
generated by the community yep and it's
special talks and topics and and and
questions that are made by the community
and now for a few minutes of us in your
day in your lives let's do it baby
alright y'all DNS I've peace bye